the honor dirt is long gone gene watches
have won 10 world's fair grand prizes
twenty eight gold medals and more honors
for accuracy than any other time fees
launching the world's most honored watch
is made and guaranteed by the Longy with
no watch company
it's time for the long-chain kala scope
a television journal of the vital issues
of they are a presentation of the long
gene with nor what's company maker of
long gene the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world honored launching good evening
this is frank night our guest on the
launch in Crona scope this evening is
Princess Alexandra Kropotkin a direct
descendant of the first Tsar of all
Russia
her father was exiled from zoara's
Russia because of his liberal views
princess Kropotkin returned to Russia in
1915 lived there through the early days
of the revolution and it was her fate to
be imprisoned by the communists in time
she escaped to America and has since
worked for the liberation of her people
may I present princess
Kropotkin our co-editors our mr. William
Bradford Huie
editor of the american mercury and mr.
Henry Hazlitt political economist and
associate editor of Newsweek magazine
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers printed from
Potkin secretary Atchison testifying on
June 26 before a congressional committee
said that America's quarrel today is not
with world communism or with the
dictators in the Kremlin but with
old-fashioned Russian nationalism he
said and I quote it is clearly said that
this process of encroachment a
consolidation by which Russia has grown
in the last 500 years from the Duchy of
Muscovy to a vast empire must be stopped
now do you agree with that statement the
issue now I never agree with mr. arason
any
that's a Machiavellian statement and I
think the rather bad one what do you
think is wrong with it from well after
all and they went communism at the
present moment that wouldn't be Russian
nationalism imperialism it'd be a
country where there was some kind of
perhaps democracy for the people well
you think that this view of the subject
tends to consolidate the Russian people
with Stalin instead of recognizing the
fact that a lot of them are opposed to
the Stalin regime
well 80% is supposed to be opposed and
probably more and I don't think that
there are very many Russians as opposed
to communist we're in the least
interested in expansion territorial
expansion or anything of the kind
what is the evidence and dangers what is
the evidence as you see it that there
that percentage of the Russian people
are opposed oh that's a long story adult
handle what to one considers is the wide
one considers its 80% it's about that
one hears that from people who will
escape from Russia from the quantities
of prisoners from their many sources of
evidence all which has been connected by
various groups now it's quite a good
deal of evidence what do you think is
the main thing that can be done to take
advantage of that situation we have
these potential allies in Russia
well anything's propaganda of course
such as being carried on perhaps
accentuated propaganda by various Radio
Free Russia and so on
friendless growing quite apart already
yes partly but I think the American
people would like to hear something from
you about actual light and Russia and
one of the things that we hear a great
deal about a Russian secret police now
in America where nobody is afraid of a
policeman
the average American finds it hard finds
it difficult to believe all the stories
we hear about the effectiveness of the
Russian police now had how is it
possible for the Russian secret police
to exert no such terror among the people
well first of all it's a quantitative
thing you'll see under the Tsar's the
secret police the Okhrana was a
personnel of about five thousand people
in Russia today there are over two
million M card names a day agents and so
on that's the Russian communist secret
police yes and how many how many people
how many Russians would you estimate
have been put in concentration camps
well that estimate varies it varies from
12 to 20 million people and how many
were in in how many political prisoners
were then an average year under the Tsar
oh the figure never exceeded much over
fifty thousand prison and in exile and
so on you see you asked how it's
possible to have instilled so much
terror first of all there is incredible
poverty and so much difficulty in energy
goes into every little thing that people
need for everyday life secondly
there's ever a year a horrible system of
spying on one another which the
Communists have managed to develop
that's a refinement that a lot electracy
I see and that's something that's new in
the police system oh yes there was there
where people who denounced others and
who were spied but not like it is now
let me ask you it once a Russian is put
in the concentration camp is there any
hope of release do they release than any
of them to come back home sometimes some
get out after they come out they usually
only allowed to live in certain places
certain towns most of them come out in
such a fearful state that they have
finished anyway they come out to die and
very few do get out of concentration
camps whether they are concentration
camps their prison camps but then the
whole of Russia is a prison camp don't
declare any way which is Kropotkin
there's certain facts which to a lot of
Americans wouldn't seem to jive with
this belief that the large majority of
the Russian people are opposed to the
regime for example they fought very well
against Germany the North Koreans the
Chinese Communists are fighting very
well they're not surrendering in mass to
the Americans in Korea they seem to have
a very good morale and if the satellites
have that good morale wouldn't be a good
supposition that the Russian soldiers
would have an even better morale
Russians have always fought well there
never been cowards that's a trait of the
Russian people but you've also got to
remember that a great many of the
younger people who were born under
common
they don't like the regime they would
welcome something different but when it
comes to fighting an enemy they'll fight
for any kind of government they always
fight but during World War two
an enormous number of Russians went over
and formed even a battalion in Germany
to fight back against Russia they all
hope that the Germans were going to
liberate them and if the Germans had
behave decently to the Russians they
would have had a tremendous number of
volunteers as it was there were nearly a
million so you think of our propaganda
were right and our treatment were right
if we ever didn't get involved in a war
why we would have wholesale desertions
and there would be a quick high collapse
of the regime there perhaps possibly yes
I certainly think the propaganda when it
reaches the Russians and a great deal of
it does now has an enormous effect and
also if they knew what was going to
happen to them but Frances said I don't
know if you know this sir new word
that's used not for deserters but
defectors but now there were in 48 and
49 they used to come over to the
American zone 5060 a day now there are
only two and the reason for that is that
nothing special has been done for them
they don't know what's going to happen
to them if they do desert will come into
the Americans oh well princess I'd like
to ask you just a few questions about
the nature of the underground and how we
can make it more effective now when I
read Gorky and dusty Eskie I got the
impression that the Russians were a
natural conspiratorial people that there
was always a
a large group that was against the
government and militantly so now today
it is such a group exists in the row in
Russia not as a group because it's
impossible for people to meet together
to talk to discuss anything you'd be
even liquidated or in a prison camp if
you had ever even thought of writing a
story about the terrible temper mr.
Stalin yes you did now well is there is
there a potential on the ground there is
oh and a no and has two ways in which we
might encourage it do you think that our
propaganda is effective now not as
effective as it might think first of all
there's a religious underground and that
really does exist I think that there are
quite a few things to be done to step up
propaganda what about the voice of
America how it gets affected all up to a
point
all the all the radio stations which are
carrying news into Russia are effective
unquestionably they're reaching many
people but I do think that they might
perhaps liven up a little bit and it's a
relic dowel as a final question I'd like
to ask in bryn Cisco Parton what do you
think we could do now to drive a wedge
what's the first step we could take now
to drive a wedge between the Kremlin and
the Russian people well I'm going to
give you a peculiar answer I think that
if the representatives of the Kremlin in
this country were treated to a little
social ostracism instead of being
invited to dinner parties if they were
ridiculed a little and that went back on
the radio I think that that might have
quite a level
effect and so you would say in summing
up princess you would say that there is
a potential underground and that
properly encouraged it can be very
hopeful for the Western world I think so
I think it can be the most hopeful thing
in the world because it's probably the
only way out of a war yes well thank you
very much for being with us the
editorial board for this edition of the
launching Cronus cope was mr. William
Bradford Huie and mr. Henry Hazlitt our
distinguished guest was Princess
Alexandra
Kropotkin the little black mounted
magnifying glass that the watchmaker
holds like a monocle in his eye is
called a loop after years of observing
watches of all times new and old the man
with the loop becomes an excellent judge
watches and we're proud of the fine
leathers about long gene watches which
come to us every day from
long-established watchmakers a typical
communication reads the quality of lawn
gene watches is beyond compare as an
experienced watchmaker the fine
workmanship commands my admiration
after years of observation of lawn genes
and other watches I am convinced that no
watch gives so much satisfaction as a
lawn gene no lasts so long yes indeed
the man with the loo knows while on gene
watches have won 10 world's fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals and so
many honors for accuracy in fields of
precise timing superlative quality
through and through makes launching the
world's most honored watch
this is Frank Knight inviting you to
join us again next week for the long
gene Cronus Cobra a television journal
of the important issues of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored launching sold and serviced by
more than four thousand leading jewelers
from coast to coast who proudly display
the emblem agency for lawn jean wit nor
watches lawn Jean watches have won ten
world's fair grand prizes twenty eight
gold medals and more honors for accuracy
than any other type EES launching the
world's most honored watch is made and
guaranteed by the lawn Jean with nor
watch company it's time for the long
gene horoscope a television journal of
the important issues of the hour brought
show you every Monday Wednesday and
Friday a presentation of the lawn gene
which noir watts company maker of
launching the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world honored lawn gene good evening
this is frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chrono scope mr. William
Bradford Huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. Donald R Rogers an
editor of the New York Herald Tribune
our distinguished guests for this
evening is the honorable Charles V
Bronson United States representative
from Indiana the opinions expressed are
necessarily those of the speaker's
Carvin Bronson our Crenna scope audience
knows you is the young freshman
congressman a Republican from Indiana
who was so instrumental in defeating the
universal military training bill now we
all know that the bill has been defeated
but we hear rumors that it's not quite
dead and that there may be more news
more activity from that direction could
you update us on that sir yes I think I
can as a matter of fact last week when I
was taking the elevator up to the House
chambers I happen to ride with Carl
Vinson the chairman of the Armed
Services Committee at that time he told
me quite off the record that he felt
that he would be out with a new UMT bill
which would be so modified that even I
could go for it dude I had to I had to
tell him that I doubt that very much
because as long as there is any of that
old UMT bill done up in a package no
matter how much cellophane and think
ribbon they put on it I'm afraid I can't
buy that kind of a program but it shows
that they are working just what's your
opposition to the old UMT bill the
administration UMT bill oh yeah there
are a lot of points there mr. Rogers in
the first place is terribly expensive
the first year will cost over 4 and 1/10
1/10 billion dollars and after that
it'll cost over 2 billion dollars a year
at $2,000 when the first year would be
the first year it's in effect of course
mr. Vinson sort of let the cat out of
the bag as to the extent he was willing
to go in compromising when he introduced
his amendment on the floor of the house
to make UMT not effective until 1955 but
the expense is a terrible factor that
two and 1/10 billion dollars for
instance amounts to more money than it
costs to send all the young men and
women in the United States that go
through college or university to school
well now so let's simplify this just a
bit for our audience many of whom have
young sons now is it true today sir that
every young man approaching every 18
every young American must anticipate
that he'll have to serve some time in
military training I think you're
absolutely right mr. Hugh of course
right now the draft is taking all of the
available right and whether we call it
whether we call it draft to the UM tea
or whatever we call it every able-bodied
young man has to face some sort of
military training now destiny right and
so the your argument the argument is
over what type of military training he's
going to get that is exactly you're not
opposed to universal military training
to the bill whether you in fact the
issue I think is very clear-cut the
issue is that we have to find some way
of getting non-veteran reservists to
replace the veteran reservists on whom
we now depend but before we get to that
point since every man must face it and
there are two plans now for it one is
the government plan which is being led
or by mr. Vinson or advocated by mr.
Venson chairman of the House Armed
Services Committee the other is your
plan of the plan that's been evolved by
you and a group of freshman congressman
in the house that's right that's right
now how what are the major differences
between the government plan and the plan
advocated by the young by the freshman
congressman I might put it this way ours
is evolutionary nose is a little
revolutionary we're taking the high
school ROTC type of program which has
existed now for many many years in which
now claim 62,000 youngsters all right
now we hear an American high number one
their plan would take all young men that
go off a train they take them away from
home that is correct your plan envisions
keeping them at home we keep them at
home where they're subjected to their
home and barn what are the influences of
home church and school would they get no
military training at a post a regular
military can at all mr. Rogers because
after their two senior years of high
school or junior and senior year they
are then taken to a six weeks summer
camp where they receive
training in the particular branch of the
service which they have chosen or to
which they've been assigned and
presumably they would also receive pay
for this surgery that's right everybody
my as not as ROTC zones all right now
your plan first would keep them at home
more that is well now what is the second
advantage that you second advantages we
do not interrupt his educational
progress our plan fits into his summer
vacation and his normal high school
instruction a young man is going to take
a long technical course in college isn't
faced with the possibility of having to
extend his education another year
because of um I believe mr. Venson as
the government spokesman has called your
plan the kindergarten plan is that a
fair criticism no I don't think so
because if my plan is the kindergarten
plan mr. Vinson and his committee on
armed services of engaging in a lot of
kindergarten activity for several years
because they have had our school ROTC
almost since the National Defense Act of
1917 authorized it and has the high
school ROTC plan been a call successful
by the military and it worked very well
several the executives on reserve
Affairs have stated that many of the
noncommissioned officers in the early
and critical days of World War two and
many of the aviation flying cadets were
young men who had received their first
military training in high school ROTC
and who jumped out ahead of the group as
a result of that pragmatics now you want
to keep them at home sir and you're also
as a congressman you've been
investigating military expenditures now
will your plan be less expensive for the
taxpayer than the plan advocated by the
government we estimate that it'll only
cost about 15% as much for instance just
to give you an example of what's
happening right now in high school in
college the Department of Defense
is able to state that they are training
two hundred and 2141
high school and college ROTC students
for a total cost of twenty million
dollars that includes all the
instructors equipment that type of thing
out-of-pocket expense is actually
running eleven dollars and fifty six
cents a piece a year all right now it's
now contrasted to what sir contrasted to
the two billion won
million dollars which it will cost to
train the trainees under the
administration plan which calls for one
instructor for each - I mean per student
they say this is $11 and 56 cents per
student
that's 1156 plus about a hundred dollars
it comes out of the 20 million yes all
right now what would the UMT the
administration's um Tea Party eight
about twenty eight hundred dollars to
Train one student for six months which i
think is a little high because I
understand you can go to Harvard or Yale
for eighteen or nineteen hundred dollars
for a whole school running multiple--
yeah that's right now it costs twenty
eight hundred dollars for the government
to Train ones young man for six months
that is right and it cost $1,800 for a
young man to go to Harvard for nine
months that's right and youyou think
that that's too much money I think
something is wrong I think there's a lot
of empire building in there a lot of new
commands will be created and a lot of
extra staffs and a lot of hike evolved
do you contend that the military
training the child was you can't call
them a child the young man the student
will receive under your program will be
comparable or as good as the military
training you'd receive as I absolutely
do if you stick to basic training which
is the only thing Congress ever
authorized in public law 51 which is the
basic legislation behind this whole plan
that's what we used to call branch in
materials right
exactly I see I have a comrade
as a matter of fact this whole scheme
grew up through our belief that if you
can take a young man and give him four
years of college ROTC six weeks of
summer camp and commissioned him as a
second lieutenant to lead men in combat
you can certainly make a private out of
a young man in the last two years of
high school with a six week summer camp
it has worked in the past I can't see
what used to make second lieutenants in
17 weeks that's right and for the good
ones I might add now congressman you and
your colleagues our freshman and
congressman yes and you're challenging
some of these old-timers who've been on
the Armed Services Committee for 30
years now what is there in your
background that leads you to think that
you might be an expert in this field as
a matter of fact I'm very humble about
that whole thing you see as close as I
can figure mr. Carl Vinson came into the
Congress the day I was born we offered
this plan to the Armed Services
Committee for their study we offered
this plan to the American Legion for
study we have tried to work with all of
these groups that exist as far as we
possibly can but we are very proud that
the common-sense practical approach of
our plan made it successful in carrying
the voice vote and the telephone and the
floor of the House of Representatives
meeting as the committee of the whole
have you had training as a psychologist
yes I have my college work is in
psychology as a matter of fact I was a
personnel consultant on military duty
never even started my five years service
in World War two
all of us who drafted this plan you see
have seen this thing left from the
standpoint of the boys with the Stars
and the boys with a white bowl and the
cuffs but all of us have been on the
under side training men and being
trained then we think that gives our
very perspective by and large the Armed
Services Committee is composed of a
majority of non veterans now sir we'd
like as finally we'd like you to give us
your prediction as to what will happen
in this struggle between the two systems
the government and the one what you're
advocating well my prediction is that
the American people are going to
evidence a continued interest we have
never had a flood of mail such as we had
on you
at the American people what an American
plan of um tea instead of a European
Asiatic type plan all they've got to do
is let their own congressmen know and
he's sittin down there waitin in
Washington waiting to hear from them and
he'll do what they want because in the
wonderful American tradition this is an
election year
well thank you mr. Branson I'm sure that
our audience has appreciated your views
thank you for being with us sir the
editorial board for this edition of the
launching Crona scope was mr. William
Bradford Huie and mr. Donald I Rodgers
our distinguished guests was the
honorable Charles be bouncing United
States representative from Indiana do
you have the problem of selecting a gift
of great prestige for someone important
to you that problem is most happily
solved with launching the world's most
honored watch because of the outstanding
quality of the watch itself and because
of what the name long Jean stands for to
the whole world long Jean stands as the
only watch in history to win the highest
of all Awards 38 times at World's Fairs
and international expositions including
10 grand prizes and twenty eight gold
medals launching also stands for the
watch of first choice in sports aviation
science and other fields of precise
timing long Jean stands for the only
watch to be classified first at the four
great government observatories
Washington Geneva q Teddington and no
shuttle the gift of great prestige for
any important occasion is launching the
world's most honored watch and
throughout the world no other name on a
watch mean so much and yet you may buy
and on or buy and proudly give the
launching watch for as little as seventy
one fifty
non gene the world's most honored watch
premiere product of the laun gene with
noir watch company since eighteen sixty
six maker of watches of the highest
character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the long gene chrono scope the
television journal of the important
issues of the hour broadcast on behalf
of launching the world's most honored
watch and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honored lawn jean
this is frank night reminding you that
long jean and wit nor watches are sold
and serviced from coast to coast by more
than four thousand leading jewelers who
proudly display this emblem agency for
lawn jean wit nor watches
the Connard
wawk wawk wawk is long gone gene watches
have won 10 world's fair grand prizes
twenty eight gold medals and more honors
for accuracy than any other timepiece
launching the world's most honored watch
is made and guaranteed by the lawn gene
with no watch company it's time for the
launching promise Co a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour brought so you every Monday
Wednesday and Friday a present on gene
which Noir what's company maker of
launching the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world honored lawn gene good evening
this is frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching Khurana scope mr. Donald I
Rogers an editor of the New York Herald
Tribune and mr. Victor Rahzel of the New
York Daily Mirror our distinguished
guests for this evening is the honorable
Christian a her sir United States
congressman from Massachusetts the
opinions expressed are necessarily those
of the speakers
congressman herder our audience knows of
you as a member of the House Foreign
Affairs Committee and as a leading
Republican in Congress I wonder if you'd
speak to assert tonight a bit about the
foreign affairs of our nation I think
perhaps the most pressing foreign
problem or perhaps most talked of
foreign problem is whether or not
General Eisenhower will run for
president as a Republican of course well
there obviously I get to express my own
opinion I happen to be very enthusiastic
for General Eisenhower
as the candidate for the on the
Republican ticket and my feelings about
the general conveyor briefly be
explained by the fact that I think he's
got a concept of the importance of our
foreign relations today that is
unequaled by many people in public life
and I have the very deep conviction that
our foreign relations condition almost
everything that happens in our domestic
affairs okay in other word a of the
conduct of our foreign affairs is the
most important factor in our domestic
life well congressman you say the
general has concept well he has been
asked by virtually everybody what those
concepts are if he's not declaring at
least can you tell us what he stands for
on foreign problems and on domestic
problems if he becomes president he has
to run this country what does general
eisenhower stand for well Richard II
cell there obviously I'm in the same
position with any other private system I
can quoted published works I could tell
you that I've talked to him as an
individual and convinced myself but he's
got an extraordinarily clear picture
welfare our role in this world is
conditioned by the relationships with
other other countries nobody can speak
for it you can have to speak for himself
when will that becomes well I'm
convinced that it will come fairly soon
after the Lisbon conference that comes
early in February but that is the time
where he has got to make at least his
last appearance as a commander in chief
in Europe now I'm again speaking without
authority I'm guessing but I think it
will come very soon after there any
political significance in the United
States any political events which might
hasten his decision and declaring
himself well there are number of things
that
happening automatically in our political
life the New Hampshire primaries come on
the 10th of March under New Hampshire
law at the end of January the 29th of
January to be exact the Secretary of
State of New Hampshire has got to notify
any potential candidate whose name may
go on the ballot and I know it will
certainly go on the ballot in New
Hampshire but he has 10 days in which to
add Roy's name from the ballot if he
sees fit to do so but don't the
Democrats have the same variety no they
have the same perogative and I think at
that stage of the game the generals got
to make a big find where the willing to
have his name go on the Republican
ballot and whether he's willing to have
you take it off the demeanor or huh
welcome to Roma there's been a great
deal of conjecture and obviously you're
convinced he's going to stand for the
presidency of the United States if he
can get the Republican nomination do you
think he can get the nomination if he
declares yes I do I think he's been
handicapped I think you've been had to
get by factors that are entirely outside
of his own control and one of them that
I'm rather bitterly critical of that I'd
like to talk about is the slowly with
which our own productive capacity in
this country has been tending out
armaments that could be used in the
setting up of the European army how does
this affect general effective very what
we the whole time schedule on which he
was supposed to operate from the point
of view of a unified command on the
arming of the minimum number of
divisions have been set way back by our
own full nation who do we imagine that
it hasn't this time lag then do the
tooling up they done I get nothing to
truly go the term like that is an excuse
that is given I think you'll find when
you analyze the picture at the time I
get been due to perfectionists in the
military establishment who've not been
satisfied with any given tank any given
plan
Gundam always wants to make a better one
until they've never given firm orders to
turn out something which could be sent
to Europe or sent to Indochina or for
that but the rivalry force our hand on
this to the Russians keep producing
better tanks guns planes they do planes
certainly well they keep producing them
what we have been doing unfortunately
has been diddling a good deal with the
perfectionist designs that we want to
turn off Marcel's blueprints I'm for
that reason I think we're at least 10
months to a year behind what we should
have been from the point of view of the
Appropriations that Congress made well
concen hurdle and you think that the
North Atlantic Treaty Organization is a
failure look don't you know you say it
has no armament not by Lovejoy the North
Atlantic Treaty Organization had a long
way to go when you're putting together
the Armed Forces of a great many
different nations under a unified
command you've got a tremendous number
of problem dealing with national pride
national sovereignty they pay schedules
of the different noncommissioned
officers the officers and everything
that is connected with making a unified
whole of a conglomerate mass of
different nationalities well that brings
up the point it was along well mr.
Churchill says that he will throw in
with us in n80 oh if we keep mr. Orr a
General Eisenhower at the command of the
European operation which sort of puts
mr. Churchill in the role of supporting
tab no it doesn't it keeps Britain out
at the general declares is he going to
the Clara is he going to stay and mr.
Churchill come in if he goes up well I
think I think you're doing now over the
foot had been termed engaged on wires
and if he questioned well I don't think
that those two things are definitely
related in otherwise I think that
generalize now can get this picture in
such shape that he can very properly
retire and that a competent successor
carry on did you talk about the about
the individual
but is the silicone of an effective
organization I don't believe it
but councilman that's not an iffy
question the prime minister to British
Empire Winston Churchill is a very
determined man he says he doesn't go in
if the general goes out now the general
may declare but what happens to the
North Atlantic Treaty Organization if
England doesn't come through but you're
a better judge of the timing of a new
story than I am
thank you saw the other hand Churchill
statement was made two days ago and then
it was followed by a very 16th state
mentality toward the the armament
problem in Europe and the relationship
of a unified Europe and I have a feeling
that his second statement completely
overshadowed the first and the first
dealing with the inevitability of I'd
now remaining in the picture but now
been superseded massless if the general
runs I don't think this question is over
yet than that who will he run with your
high in the Republican ranks your
booming Eisenhower for president have
you people considered a running mate for
General Eisenhower no I don't think that
that is something that needs to be
considered at this moment the convention
time it's still six months away frankly
like it live primary consideration is
getting out now inundated in the first
and you have some doubt of that well got
out about that but cuz you've got
certain factors today that are working
against tight now in the picture and
let's not minimize it which is awesome
well today with these candles that are
developing day after day that are
undermining people's faith in the
administration's ability to carry on and
on it administration in the tax
department in a lot of very department
the post office Department other
departments of the government there is a
growing conviction that the Republicans
can win with any ticket whatsoever
a dangerous supposition is that I mean
for the Republic well from what have you
tears I think we've been deluded
same illusion if you want to call it
that before yeah don't I don't want to
see us do it again and by any candidate
you mean senator Ted well I mean some
depth and I'm not minimizing some to
that of an individual I've been a
personal fan of his for 30 years but
senator Taft is a fine individual who
from the point of view of the ordinary
rules of the game would be entitled to
the nomination for his contribution to
the body do you think he didn't win sir
if my principal reason for feeling so
strongly about I know as a very able and
cops in person either I think that he
can win and that he has a very much
better chance of winning and I think
that terribly important from the point
of view of the future of this country
well congressman murder we certainly
appreciate you coming with us
you have enlightened us a good deal
about general Eisenhower's chances as
campaign we appreciate you being with us
tonight
thank you sir the editorial board for
this edition of the launching Cronus
Cove was listed on a Rogers and mr.
Victor Rahzel our distinguished guests
was the honorable Christian a writer
United States congressman from
Massachusetts
the worldwide prestige of launching
watches is proof of their unsurpassed
dependability and accuracy these
qualities are the result of the
extraordinary excellence in the design
and the manufacture of the laun Jean
watch movement the beating heart of
every launching watch here is the
matured product of the skill and
experience acquired through 85 years of
watchmaking the ultra slow motion camera
reveals the smooth flawless mechanism of
the laun Jean balanced assembly the
guardian of the accuracy of the watch
through his magnifying glass the skilled
watchmaker sees in addition the precious
hand finishing of essential parts which
makes the launching watch so superior so
outstanding yes there are tangible
reasons why launching watches have 110
world's fair grand prizes twenty eight
gold medals and so many honors for
accuracy in fields of precise timing
when next you buy a watch for yourself
or as a gift
remember if you pay 70 150 or more for a
watch you're paying the price of a lawn
chain and you should insist on getting a
launching the world's most honored watch
premiere product of the lawn Jean with
no BOTS company since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches of the highest
character
this is Frank Nuys again reminding you
that the launch in chrono scope is
brought to you three times weekly every
Monday Wednesday and Friday so won't you
join us every monday wednesday and
friday evening at this same time for the
launching promise code a television
journal of the important issues of they
are broadcast on behalf of launching the
world's most honored walks and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn jean sold and serviced from
coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
displayed the emblem agency for lawn
jean wit nor watches
time for the lawn team Chronicle a
television journal of the important
issues of the earth a presentation of
the lawn gene which noir Watts country
maker of launching the world's most
honored wat and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honoured lawn
gene good evening this is David Ross may
I introduce our co-editors for this
edition of the launching promise talk
mr. William Bradford Huie and mr.
Richard Waddell management editor of
Business Week magazine our distinguished
guest for this evening is the honorable
Clifford case United States
representative from you Turkey mr. case
many of our viewers of course know that
you're a veteran congressman from Rahway
New Jersey you've been in Congress since
1944 and that's right and particularly
during the last few weeks you've been a
part of operation Commodore you've been
a part of these people who've been
sitting down in the Commodore hotel and
getting the new administration ready to
take over now so there's a lot of public
interest in and what you've been doing
at the Commodore and the first question
is this sir is all of this organization
work that you've been doing for the new
administration is this an unprecedented
effort has it ever happened before so
far as I know it is unprecedented
certainly nothing like this has happened
in the past 20 years
could you give our viewers some
indication of the size of the effort how
many people have been in and poured in
it right now I guess that we're about at
the peak and I think there's something
like 125 people there altogether the
great bulk of that consists of clerical
help and then there are several people
in the rather special category like you
Scott and myself most of the rest of the
men are people who are going into the
new administration everybody from
General Eisenhower and mr. Dulles on
down 125 of you have been reporting
they're for work every morning since the
election and working pretty much pretty
much your job I understand part of your
job at least has been to collect some
money to pay for this yes that vendor
who will pay the final bill are the
bills pay they're not all paid but they
I'm sure they all will be paid we have
had to raise money for this for this
headquarters there isn't any federal
appropriation for it and it's an
expensive thing to have 55 rooms now
shift interim period well there are
various possibilities it seems to me and
they all ought to be explored I'm not
sure that I can see quickly any reason
why there should be such a long delay
between Election Day and inauguration
day and the purpose of course of the
whole operation is to make this
transition from one administration to
another as smooth as possible without
any lag how much is the operation cost
geology well in the weekly cost of it
has gradually increased as the
president-elect has named additional
people to his staff and they have come
to the headquarters and taken up their
duties right now I expect it's something
like in the neighborhood of 25 thousand
dollars a week and and how are you
paying the twenty-five thousand now how
you pay upon it a considerable amount I
don't know exactly what it would total
has been raised just by people who have
sent in subscriptions contributions
knowing that the organization is in
existence and it is there any possible
ground for criticism of such an
operation for financing it in such a
manner it seems to me that there is no
proper ground and I've heard no
suggestion of producing any difficulty
in collecting the money no but there
hasn't been an organized drive to raise
money your efforts have been something
some fields directors in another way or
if you have done some other things
there's been some talk to
I've been looking over the congressional
list to find out those whom you think
might be the proper men to carry out
some of Eisenhower's program well I I
ought to say right now that my position
and and congressman Scott's position too
has not been that we are not in any way
assigned to that to that job by the
administration or the incoming
administration we are there to do
everything that has to be done for which
our experience and a yes call the
approachable approach between captain
Eisenhower it's going to work out smooth
I have every confidence that that there
will be a complete completely harmonious
operational between senator Chapman and
Congress in general and the president
congressman since you have since you are
an original Eisenhower man and since
you've had all this experience and
helping to prepare the way for the new
administration I'm sure that you can
give our viewers some valuable hints as
to what to expect when the show moves on
down to Washington on the 20th now sir
specifically is anything dramatic likely
to happen during the first few weeks
after eisenhower it becomes president
well in the sense that I think your
question implies no there has been a
very dramatic happening extended over
the period beginning about 8:30 on
election day and continuing right on now
and it's going to continue but in the
sense of dramatic and spectacular moves
I don't think that that they are in the
a in the wind this is going to be a
process which is a solid accomplishment
rather than a spectacular one the war in
careers not like to the end quickly or
taxes to be reduced drastically or any
New Deal legislation be repeals and uh
well with you I I'm sure that the kind
of thing that your question implies is
not going to happen that way
I know
I have the deepest confidence that we
are going to get the war in Korea ended
sooner than we would otherwise the Texas
will come down sooner than otherwise
they would and that sound legislative
programs are going to be connected and
good things carried out develop further
but I don't look for it lightning struck
with the current I think you mean is
well the big difference is undoubtedly
one of the differences in the one one
that I'm interested in is the business
men who have gone to Washington tear
world gone to the Commodore and will be
going to Washington do you think that
their organization of the executive
branch of the government will improve
and even save money for the government
as a operation I'm sure that the
administration will do that and that the
wisdom and ability leaders from business
from Eisenhower is putting in his
cabinet and in his administration will
be a great help in that direction yes
now so who are they who are the brain
trusted with this new administration
well that again implies that there's
little coterie of people behind the
scenes who were running the show and I
couldn't if there were such and and I
knew about it I wouldn't be able to say
so as a matter of fact I don't believe
there is that kind of thing there what
I'm striking at sir I'm trying to get at
this has been billed as a new era
something new is happening in Washington
on January 20th but most people are now
most American adults and most people
less than fifty years old there's
nothing like this has happened since
1932
how can you illustrate for our viewer is
it what the difference is going to be
between this new admitted Republican
administration what we've had the past
20 years well we've had for the past at
least the latter part of this 20 years
an administration that's been running
down the administration that by the
weight of its cumulated mistakes and the
mere fact that it's been in office so
long has been getting slower and slower
grinding to a
and we know how coming into office on
the 20th of January priests presaged by
the Republican Congress which took
office last Saturday and administration
that is fresh and comes with vigor with
none of the handicaps or the barnacles
that have attached to the oval and with
a complete dedication to the single
purpose of doing the best possible job
in foreign affairs and in domestic
affairs and no entanglements when I I
have the greatest confidence that the
results which are expected are going to
be realized one of the problems that
some people think that the Eisenhower
administration will face perhaps in 1953
is a a recession now you have said in
your campaign speeches for reelection in
New Jersey that the Republican Party
must do nothing to earn the title of the
depression party or party of privilege
or the indifference towards the general
public will they move quickly if there's
any sign of that if there is any sign of
that's what I am sure the administration
will take all proper and necessary
action actually in my talks to which you
refer I was talking about a reputation
rather than an actuality something that
had been successfully foisted on us by
certain branches of the Democratic Party
in many people's minds and and I was
pointing out that we should not accept
that and and must not and I'm sure we
will not do anything to tell a lie -
well mr. case you are a very influential
New Jersey politician in your own right
sir and there's a very limited a and
from a very fine district that's what it
what have you promised your district to
get them down there
in this new Congress I'm a very lucky
congressman because mine is not a port
for our district in any sense we have no
great public works that are desired and
then that are there they mean your
district didn't mourn anything
well my district wants pardon me this is
not saying that it's got it but it wants
to good solid representation which they
must think you were solid representation
since you let Eisenhower in I'm sorry
you started this yeah I'd let those back
speak for themselves that was a little
bit special and there were special
reasons for that you accept the
candidacy for governor and some people
say that you were going to be offered
that that would be a most flattering
offer I don't believe anybody and
political life returned it down but I
prefer to wait till it was offered
before I say yes as a final question sir
that it's been said that the new
administration is going to be weak on on
politicians it is going to have a lot of
businessmen but they aren't going to be
any very experienced politicians in the
administration itself how do you think
that there's going to be a shortage of
politicians no not in the right sense
both in the in the in the administration
itself in the executive side and of
course in Congress where we have
experienced politicians men from way
back who know the trade and properly I
am sure that we will get to we will have
no difficulty in handling the political
side of this thing in a private way well
thank you very much for being with us
this evening check the opinions you
heard our speakers expressed tonight are
entirely their own the editorial board
for this edition of the launching
promise cope was mr. William Bradford
Huie and mr. Richard Waddell management
editor of Businessweek magazine our
distinguished guests was the honorable
Clifford case United States
representative from New Jersey
discriminating people the world over
find and launching the qualities they
seek in a very fine walk greater
accuracy for instance now the record of
long gene watches in observatory
accuracy competitions is unexcelled over
the years long teen watchers have
established many
it's won countless awards for individual
watches and series of waters and the
Great observatories nor chateau geneva
washington q Teddington and across lawns
een is the only watch in history to win
ten world's fair grand prizes and
twenty-eight gold medal awards if you
two are interested in a watch of
superior quality either for yourself or
as an important gift you will choose
well to choose launching the world's
most honored watch for a long team watch
offers you exclusive styling
impressive appearance greater accuracy
and the assurance of a long long life
yet you may buy and own or proudly give
a long jean watch for as little as
seventy one fifty launching the world's
most honored watch the world's most
honored gift premier product two belongs
in with noir watch company since
eighteen sixty six maker of watches of
the highest character we invite you to
join for the long team chroma scope a
television journal of important issues
of the hour broadcast on behalf of
launching the world's most honored walks
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world honoured launching this is
david ross reminding you that lord jean
and wit nor watches are sold and
serviced from coast to coast by more
than four thousand leading jewelers who
proudly display this emblem agency for
launching with nor what
it's time for the launching promise Co a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought so you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which
snore watts company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our co
editors for this edition of the
launching Chronos code mr. William
Bradford Huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. Henry Hazlitt
contributing editor of Newsweek magazine
our distinguished guest for this evening
is mr. Franklin D Roosevelt jr. United
States representative from New York mr.
Roosevelt were very happy to welcome you
to the Chronicle program this evening
I'd like to begin by asking you what you
thought of the charges that Senator
McCarthy made against governor Stevenson
Mr hazard first of all may I express my
gratitude for your inviting me here
tonight
as for the McCarthy speech tonight I
unfortunately was not able to see all of
it here all of it I did get the last
part of it where the senator from
Wisconsin was once again bringing in the
affidavit that Governor Stevenson made
in the histroy
in which of course governor Stevenson
testified in writing by his affidavit
only to the fact that when he knew his
in the State Department his then had a
reputation a good reputation in the
community and that was all but Senator
McCarthy as usual tried to read much
more into it now but do you think that
Governor Stevenson showed good judgment
and making that deposition I think that
as an attorney and as a citizen in our
procedure of justice in the courts he
had had an obligation to state what he
knew about the reputation his had in the
community at that time it was not his
opinion of his his reputation it was his
opinion of the reputation he's had in
the community at that time well granted
that he had the duty to speak if he
thought that a perjurer was a loyal
citizen did it show good judgment in
thinking that well of course he had not
been convicted of perjury at the time
that Governor Stevenson made that
affidavit and that was the decision of
the jury after the his trial
well first his trial has a hung jury
amount well do you think it would show
that governor Stevenson can't tell a
communist when he sees one so to speak
no I don't think it shows that at all
well she knows what McCarthy would like
it to show on the McCarthy speech sir do
you think that it might be effective for
the Republicans we're not having heard
the whole speech I can't say I don't
think that McCarthy is effective for the
Republicans for one very simple reason
that I think the American people have
realized that McCarthy has crucified the
character and the reputation without
evidence of too many Americans and
secondly that not one single person has
been convicted as a result of mr.
McCarthy's efforts the mother Justice
Department at the same time has
convicted 33 well-known communist
leaders we're moving on to the to the
campaign sir I believe that you at least
made one favorable statement about
General Eisenhower in 1948 did in March
of 1948 I did make a statement saying
that I felt that General Eisenhower
could unify the country no I said when
when did your enthusiasm begin to lag
for general eisenhower within the three
weeks that followed that statement I
discovered that the impressions that I
had of general Eisenhower's position on
the issues could not be verified and
that General Eisenhower did not would
express himself on the issues nor was he
a candidate where did those impressions
come from mr. Roosevelt
that was 1948 I say that they probably
were a general idea that people had
about the fact that Eisenhower at that
time certainly was a very humane and the
great military leader and certainly was
highly respected both here and
throughout the world I think he still is
respected and admired as a great
military leader
well now about the campaign that the
Democrats have waged against General
Eisenhower do you feel sir that any of
the charges leveled at him have been
unfair well I haven't documented all the
charges that have been leveled against
him I've been pretty busy being positive
in this campaign on behalf of Governor
Stevenson and of course my own
reelection I'd say that the main charge
against General Eisenhower has been not
that he has failed to repudiate McCarthy
and Jenna who crucified his own great
hero general Marshall but that he has
positively gone out and endorsed these
people the very essence of the old guard
Republicans and I think that the charge
that he is now a captive of the old God
is a justified charge I think that can
be shown by his acceptance of Senator
tats prepared statement prepared in
Cincinnati and he brought it to Columbia
for his meeting with Eisenhower and
Eisenhower accepted it well as it's a
great crime for mr. Eisenhower who was
running on a Republican ticket to be
supporting so to speak the views of mr.
Republican well he he concurred mr.
Republican at Chicago and then was
conquered by mr. Republican at Columbia
University I don't think it's a crime of
course not he's and this is a free
country I don't think it will help him
though with the American people because
I don't think that Senator Taft is a
what he wasn't nominated by the
Republicans so he doesn't even have the
Republican support two questions on
President Truman in the first place or
do you think that any of Truman's
tactics have been unfair in this
campaign I think that it's hard to say
that they're unfair for the simple
reason that we know Harry Truman is a
tough fighter in any case
pain that's how a won the election in
1948 I think that some of the things he
has said have hurt some people
their sensitivities on the other hand I
think he has aroused the Democratic
Party and I think that this campaigning
has been helpful but I'm sure I
Roosevelt I'd like to ask this question
whether that isn't applying a sort of
double standard now why can't you say
about Senator McCarthy he's a tough
fighter and he's been effective why is
it all right let's rumor the well Wyatt
well I'm asking you why you apply what
seems to be a double standard of inner
endo how about the inner Endor that mr.
Truman made that general eisenhower was
anti-semitic and anti-catholic he didn't
know wait a minute he did not say that
we made the innuendo I know what he said
was that and actually he didn't even
deliver the speech himself although he
approved the speech what he said was
that General Eisenhower was now
endorsing positively those men who had
passed and supported the McCarran bill
which is selective and ante ratio mr.
Rose any polish it's auntie the Italian
it's auntie Eastern European and so
forth well governor Stevenson hasn't
been repudiating any of the candidates
who the Democratic candidates who
favored McCarran difference between
repudiation and endorsement that's all
at Truman said that Eisenhower's gone
out of his way to endorse these
candidate well hasn't mr. Stevenson
endorsed some of the people who voted
through the Karen Act the Democrats I
don't know I don't know Governor
Stevenson has endorsed anybody and it
hasn't been heralded such as the
endorsement miss McCarthy than the
Roosevelt I'm sure that I viewers want
to know something about you and your own
campaign so you have trolled you
represent one of the big Westside
districts in New York City now has your
own has your own campaign going well
I've been spending five days a week four
or five meetings a night meeting with my
constituents discussing the issues with
I have a very interesting district it's
a very independent district I'd say that
it is liberal it's progressive of course
I hope they react me to Congress well
one on a four freedoms platform didn't
you the first time I ran I I ran on the
Liberal Party candidacy and also the
independent four freedoms party it's a
traditionally Democratic constituency is
no I'd say that it's traditionally
independence unite in 1949 they elected
me I was not the Democratic candidate
then they voted for mayor impelliteri
quite overwhelmingly when he ran as an
independent 1950 they voted for mr. Haly
when he ran as an independent in the
Liberal Party candidate in 1951 and one
other question about the family sir I
believe that one of your brothers are
supporting General Eisenhower is this
unusual it's a defection in the
Roosevelt family like this no I don't
think it's particularly unusual we
practice what we preach in the Roseville
family we believe in freedom of speech
freedom of thought and the right of
everyone to express himself freely and
he feels called upon to do so I frankly
though I don't think Johnny's going to
influence any votes I don't think I am
but I think my mother is well what are
your mother taking an active part in the
last few days of the campaign he
certainly is she's introducing governor
Stevenson to the Madison Square Garden
rally tomorrow night and as a final
question mr. Roosevelt do you expect any
dramatic moves in the last part of the
campaign no I don't look for any
dramatic moves I think that general
eisenhower shot is what when he said
he'd go to Korea personally what'd he do
when he got there he didn't say I think
that the American people will vote to
continue the prosperity under the
Democrats and continue the hope for
peace in the world through the United
Nations the point for program in NATO
well thank you sir for being with us
thank you the opinions that you've heard
our speakers expressed tonight are
entirely there all the editorial board
for this edition of the long Jean Cronus
cope was mr. William Bradford Huie
and mr. Henry Hazlitt our distinguished
guest was mister Franklin D Roosevelt
jr. United States representative from
New York
during the past weeks the words of some
of our speakers spoken during the heat
of the political campaign have a vote
considerable comments and occasional
criticism now at this time the launching
with noah watts company puts aside its
usual commercial message to give our
editors an opportunity to explain to you
the policy of the launch in Cronus code
for this purpose we present mr. William
Bradford Huie as a magazine editor about
once a year I give a policy statement to
the readers and tonight as an editor of
The Chronicle I'll give a policy
statement to you
launching Whitner began this program
first on it once a week basis and now
for more than a year we've operated
three times a week over a very large
nationwide network and we are pleased
that so many of you have liked the
program now here's what we do regardless
of political persuasion we bring the
most important people in America right
into your living room we seat them
comfortably and then in a forthright but
friendly manner we ask them the
questions that we think you would like
to ask and in doing this we take risk
it's a hazardous business of bringing
guests into other people's living rooms
and sometimes when we bring a rather
controversial character on one side of
the other you don't like him and a great
many of you protest now when this
happens we are sorry but quite honestly
what can we do neither I know the
sponsors nor the network exercise any
control over what said we're not censors
we have to take the risk you and I of
free speech we ask the questions and you
take the risks forgive what answers you
get then to we editors are are often
criticized because we don't rip into
some guests because we don't try to
refute what he has to say
or to embarrass him and I particularly
get criticized because as a writer I
have some reputation as a Ripper but
here we don't do any ripping we don't
smash any ink wells and we are quite
proud of the fact that in all our
programs we've never had a guest who
went away thinking that he'd been
treated unfairly so during our second
year we expect to bring you stimulating
provocative views from the most active
men and women in the world you examine
them you look into their eyes on these
big TV close-ups and you decide what you
think of them now that's our policy
thank you
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the long gene chroma scope the
television journal of the important
issues of the are broadcast on behalf of
launching the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world honored launching this is
frank night reminding you that lawn gene
and Whitner watches are sold in service
from coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display this emblem agency for long jean
wit nor watson
came from Moscow a television journal of
the important issues of the hour brought
so you every Monday Wednesday and Friday
a presentation of the lawn gene which
nor what's company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night they introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the Long
gene Khurana scope mr. William Bradford
Huie editor of the american mercury and
mr. Gunther Stillman associate editor of
the american mercury our distinguished
guest for this evening is the honorable
frederick our coudair jr. United States
congressman from New York the opinions
expressed are necessarily those of the
speakers mr. coudair our audience of
course knows that you are a
distinguished and veteran member of the
Congress of the United States and
tonight since there is a lot of interest
in the presidential campaign some of our
audience I'm sure would like to know
something of the problems of the 435
congressmen who are running for
re-election now you of course are
standing for reelection in your district
are you not sir that is quite right too
and for you early for your fourth term I
believe it is I've completing a third
term and running for the fourth term
that's quite right and what is your
district sir the 17th the district of
New York that runs up and down the
middle of Manhattan on the east side
largely and part of it runs straight
through to the East River from Fifth
Avenue and it goes down below Washington
Square now is that known as one of the
Silk Stocking districts in New York it
was known as a Silk Stocking district
when people wore silk stockings but
nobody wears stockings anymore so I
think possibly that's no would you say
it's a typical district in
in metropolitan area I think it's a fair
cross-section of the population of lead
Manhattan mr. coudair do you think that
now with mr. Eisenhower having been
nominated as the Republican presidential
candidate that your chances for your own
re-election are have improved well I
have very little doubt that with a
ticket that we've got now headed by
General Eisenhower and my former
colleague in the house senator Nixon
that we're going to win I'm quite sure
that in my own district the Republicans
will carry all offices from the
president down viewer Republican do you
think that General Eisenhower is proving
himself to be a good campaigner in the
coming I think he started off in great
shape
I think the exchange between the
president and the general the last 24
hours about the invitation to visit the
White House and put Truman's yoke around
his neck at the start but very much to
the credit of the general Excel he was
very much on the job and very alert to
the issues you don't believe then as
some critics of charge that General
Eisenhower may not be the type of man
who can make the case against the
Democratic Party by no means I think you
make the most of it and I think you
supply the most effective leadership I
think we're going to have a fine
smashing campaign that's going to result
in victory myself and you think that
that most of the of the Republican
members of Congress who are carrying on
their campaigns in their own districts
that they are are satisfied with the
national ticket and the help that they
will get from the National ticket as far
as I've been in contact with them yes of
course I can't speak for all 435 well
now in new york new york state of course
is a pivotal state in this election and
there's a great deal of conjecture as to
how the state will go now in 1948 i
believe the state went for governor
dewey but that
largely because or may have been because
mr. Wallace was running and polled a
very large vote now this year without a
third ticket in the in the picture how
do you think New York State's likely to
go well obviously it will be a good deal
more difficult to carry New York without
the help of a split in the opposition
but I think all of our Republicans are
going to stand firmly together I think
they're going to make this fight without
reservation I think the issues are very
great and very important and I'm
personally
confident that the people of New York
will appreciate the issue sufficiently
to throw out the democratic
administration in Washington and elect
generalizing well now the the various
voting groups in New York do you think
the general eisenhower poll will run
strong among the labor groups the youth
labor union groups in New York State
it's my own impression that there's a
very large element among the so-called
labor vote that will vote Republican
they voted Republican before and not so
long ago if you'll remember great many
of them must have voted for Bob Taft in
Ohio when he was re-elected and I think
their tax conscious and I think they're
conscious of inflation and I think a
great many of the so-called labor vote
will support the Republican ticket mr.
coudair there has been a lot of talk
about the so-called Negro vote what do
you think about the Negro vote in New
York State well of course I can only yes
I can only speak for the Negro vote in
New York State my own impression there
again based upon my knowledge of that
Eisenhower's going to get a great deal
of support I think from the Negro vote
and rightly so because it's New York
State after all that was the pioneer in
the anti-discrimination Acts I think the
New York legislature was the first state
legislature to passed the act and I
think many of our New York Negroes
realize that as far more chance of
achieving their aspirate
and objectives under a Republican
administration in Washington then under
a Democratic administration well let's
come quickly down to two the problem in
your own district sir now I believe the
presidential candidates are waiting
probably until Labor Day to launch their
campaigns are you waiting until Labor
Day to start your campaign no no mister
you II I am NOT I have been campaigning
unceasingly since about the 15th day of
July when opposition petitions were
filed in the Republican primary so I
have a primary fight on my hands first
which comes to a head on primary day on
August 19th and after that if enough
Republicans come out to vote for me I
still have the fight against the
Democratic Liberal Party candidate
through to Election Day that's a very
interesting situation for our audience
because you've actually been out rubbing
shoulders and shaking hands already with
your constituency now what what sort of
government do you think your
constituency here wants during the next
two to four years if by that you mean
what are people thinking about in the
district I would say the number one
issue is taxation taxes are eating us
alive all of us said one editorial in
the Daily News one day and my impression
is that the voters in my district are
very conscious of the fact that taxes
are eating them alive and that means
spending and government waste and all it
goes with it I think that's almost the
number one issue subject of course the
war and the famine our economy now don't
your people in your district think that
this country is enjoying great
prosperity I think a great many of our
people are aware of the fact that that's
on an artificial foundation on an
inflation foundation and they're scared
to death of where it's going to lead
them and they'd like to get down to a
firm foundation
balanced budgets less public spending
and less taxation that's the kind of
thing that means a solid stable
prosperity which assures the future and
more than anything else
Shores the future value of the dollars
that they save and are now making mr.
Qadir do you think that after the
election if the Republican Party should
win the election a balanced budget will
be possible do you think was the
armament effort and everything that is
going on today it is really possible to
reduce taxes and work with a balanced
budget because that's a very big
question but I think there's a pretty
clear answer to it certainly there's a
far greater chance of balancing the
budget on a lower level and reducing
taxes in a shorter time with a
Republican administration with
Eisenhower in the White House and
Republican majorities in both houses
we'll get a much more prudent financial
management we'll have far less waste we
love very will have no corruption and
we'll have efficient management that's
found the mean very large reductions in
planning and ultimately taxes within the
very near future now you say that your
people are you think your people are
most concerned about the reduction of
taxes now is that because of some
special characteristics of your
constituency I don't think so I don't
have any farmers in you I don't have to
have any farmers and I suppose perhaps
it's because in the city district like
mine there are fewer people who are
getting government handouts so the less
conscious of the handout aspect of
government then the pay in taxes aspect
of your constituents are only paying in
there under paying out
they're very conscious of it and they
don't like it a bit
I see now sir do you think this do you
think that there likely to be any
surprises this year do you think this is
likely to be an extraordinary election
year in which things that even the
political seers are won't foresee you
think that in on November the 5th 1952
that we're likely to wake up with some
surprises well I think governor
Stevenson and the Democrats may have
some surprises it's my impression that
there's a very deep-seated and
passionate demand for a fundamental
change in Washington I think people are
so anxious for a change that they're not
going to accept any mere change of faith
such as Truman's of Stevenson and
they're going to insist upon the kind of
a change that only comes with a change
of party you think that that perhaps is
a large group in the center for instance
that that may surprise some of the
people who are predicting the election
results that's my confident hope I think
that's what's going to swing the
election West today I'm sure that our
audience is very much appreciated your
use tonight and thank you for being with
us sir thank you for letting me come on
toward it the editorial board for this
edition of the launching Chronos cope
was mr. William Bradford Huie and mr.
Gunther Stillman our distinguished
guests was the honorable Frederick R
coudair jr. United States congressman
from New York
to the true connoisseur of fine watches
no other name on a watch means so much
as launching the world's most honored
watch such discriminating men and women
appreciate the elegance of lawn jean
watches the greater accuracy and their
faithfulness worldwide acclaim confirms
their judgment for among the world's
fine watches lawn Jean alone has won ten
world's fair grand prizes twenty eight
gold medal awards and highest honors for
accuracy from government observatories
because of inherent accuracy and
dependability sports and contests
associations the world over have made
lawn jean their official watch yes to
the connoisseur of fine watches no other
name on a watch means so much as
launching and yet do you know that you
may buy and proudly wear or give a long
jean watch for as little as seventy one
fifty lawn jean the world's most honored
watch premier product of the lawn jean
wit nor watch company since eighteen
sixty six maker of watches of the
highest character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the long gene promise code a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour broadcast on behalf
of launching the world's most honored
watch and with no distinguished
companion to the world honoured
launching this is frank night reminding
you that long jean and wit nor watches
are sold and serviced from coast to
coast by more than four thousand leading
jewelers who proudly display this emblem
agency for launching with noir watches
the world honored is long gone gene
watches have won 10 world's fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals and more
honors for accuracy than any other
timepiece launching the world's most
honored watch is made and guaranteed by
the long gene with no watch company
it's time for the launching cornerstone
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
monday wednesday and friday a
presentation of the laun gene which nor
wats company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching Cronus Co Colonel Anson Talbot
an editor of the New York Herald Tribune
and mr. William Bradford Huie editor of
the american mercury our distinguished
guest for this evening is the honorable
fred regard coudair jr. United States
representative from New York the
opinions expressed are necessarily those
of the speakers mr. coudair our
horoscope audience many of them remember
that you inspired the investigation of
communist activity in the New York
schools recently and particularly they
know you now as a fighting member of the
House Appropriations Committee who is
trying to do something about what you
think is excessive government spending
they're familiar with this rather
sensational resolution that you have
recently introduced now is the first
question sir
will you tell us first what this
resolution is that you've introduced in
Congress fundamentally mr. Yuri this
resolution provides the only practical
method by which the people of this
country can effectively save themselves
from complete bankruptcy and stop
spending at a reasonable level all right
now it's a resolution to to halt
spending and to bring it to what you
call a reasonable level now specifically
how will it do that the reasonable level
that must be applied in the same level
that every householder applies in his
own personal affairs the limitation must
be available income and available
income in this case of course means the
proceeds of the intolerably heavy tax
burden that the American people are
suffering under the day and I say that
our government must not and cannot go on
spending more than the people are
willing and able to pay in taxes and
that's precisely what this
administration means to do unless we can
stop mr. coudair these aren't normal
times and I wonder just how what you
proposed would cut into our proposed
expenditures for the national defense
and for foreign aid well obviously if
any effective reduction is to be made in
the fantastic proposal to the President
to spend something like eighty five
billion dollars for three years in a row
there must be some reduction in the
enormous requests for military funds and
some reduction in the foreign aid
requests now they the suggestion that
there be such a reduction is obviously
not revolutionary because my resolution
was specifically and expressly endorsed
at the time I announced it by none other
than former ambassador Douglas our
United States Ambassador to Great
Britain who as much as any other man was
responsible for the Marshall Plan and
responsible for the development of the
North Atlantic Treaty Organization
now the Douglas said to me in a letter
that a seventy one limitation must be
adhered to in order to save the solvency
and security of humans that's less
before we kick these billions around sir
most of us don't know much don't know
the difference between seventy billions
and eighty-five billions now you're
telling us tonight that our taxes these
very heavy taxes that have been levied
are likely to bring in about 71 billions
during 1952 is that correct sir that is
the president's own estimate I say now
and you do you believe that we have
reached the wise limit for peacetime
taxation I haven't any
doubt about it but I don't ask you or
our listeners to rely upon my opinion
Senator George who's chairman of the
Finance Committee in the Senate a
Democrat and mr. Dalton who is chairman
of ways means in the house which imposes
the taxes and a great many others in the
Congress have said we've reached the
limit they're not going to feed now
there you you're saying that there is an
agreement between both Republicans and
and Democrats that 71 billions is a tax
limit now that we can't do above that
agreement isn't exactly the way this
recognition recognition won't pay any
recognition and the president wants to
spend 85 billions or 14 billions more
and and your resolution is designed to
prevent that commander how would your
resolution prevent that sir it would
impose by congressional action a
limitation of 71 billion dollars upon
spending he would be forbidden to spend
a dime more than the 71 billion and if
the resolution passes he would be
required to submit within 30 days a
brand-new budget dividing up to 71
million piece of pie now is there a
growing support for your resolution what
what evidence is of support have you
found sir the most amazing evidence of
support quite frankly indicating perhaps
the beginning of a grassroots taxpayers
revolt back home only today Senator
Morse of Oregon known as one of the
great liberals on the Republican side
demanded a 15 billion dollar reduction
with 9 billion out of foreign aid and
the military establishment Senator Paul
Douglas also a Democrat from Illinois
one of the favorite liberals on the
Democratic side himself said the other
day that we ought to take at least 4
billion out of the military
establishment and something like a
million
I have or two out of the foreign aid
program so there is a universal
expression of desire to cut by great
many of these fellows in the House and
Senate but there's no vehicle to make it
effective unless something is done as is
suggested in my resolution mr. coudair
suppose the Chinese Communists march
into Indochina this spring where would
that leave your plan do you mean by that
colonel that what do we do if there
should be another great war scare and a
serious chat of immediate third war
operation yes exactly
well I think the answer to that is very
simply that Congress is always in
session these days unfortunately for
members and for the country sometimes so
that any legislation that we enact now
or any budget that we adopt now on the
assumption that we're in for a long pull
at high level could be tossed overboard
24 hours by congressional action we're
always there how would your budget plan
prevent enactment of unit legislation
for universal military training I don't
think it would affect the matter one way
or the other if the administration and
the professional military honestly
wanted a UMT and were honestly
determined to develop a UMT as an
alternative to the present in tolerably
large standing forces there'd be
enormous savings in it but I don't I'm
not so sure they mean to use it that way
I'm going to wait to see congressman for
our listeners tonight can you illustrate
quickly just how these budget arguments
in Congress affect the average American
family let the average American family
ask itself what its dollars were worth
ten years ago when they were worth a
hundred cents and what they're worth
today in purchasing power at fifty-three
cents and when they answer that question
they'll know what excessive federal
spending has done the the devil in
inflation fundamentally is federal
spending of more money than we take
in taxes that is the source of inflation
and that is what every American is
paying for every morning on in the cost
of his breakfast food and his dinner and
his radio in his car and everything else
are you saying that if your resolution
can be passed and if the government is
held to 71 billions spending this year
that that will reduce the threat of
inflation
I think it's the sorest way to limit
inflation and to reestablish something
like a sound financial basis in the
United States so that people can look
forward to some measure to security and
certainty in their day-to-day operation
always barring of course the possibility
of an all-out war which would upset all
plans obviously how close is your
resolution to actually being realized
but at the moment it's resting in a
heavily weighted New Deal Committee of
the house a great step forward was made
last Monday or Tuesday when the
Republican policy committee unanimously
endorsed it with a very strong statement
by Minority Leader Joe Martin of
Massachusetts I think that means that
having made it a party issue our people
will press for it and enough Democrats
have committed themselves to the general
proposition substantial reduction that
I'm sure if it ever can be gotten to the
floor it will be passed now sir there
are some people I know that would like
to help you
would you like your prediction as to
whether you can do something now and
whether you can get this resolution
passed and what can any average American
who would like to help you what can he
do mr. Healy despite any fears to the
contrary we are still living in a free
country Americans are still master than
their fate if they choose to assert
themselves all we need is a
grass roots revolt there is nothing more
sensitive on earth than a member of
Congress in an election year all they've
got to do was hear from the folks back
home and believe me they'll get action
now I believe certain to sum up for our
audience I believe that you say that you
are trying to force the government to
spend only 71 billions and only what we
will be realized from taxes that you
think that you can't accomplish that if
there are enough American citizens who
will write to their congressman and try
to impose a system of economy on the
present government thank thank you very
much for being with us the editorial
board for this edition of the launching
Cronus cope was Colonel Ansel Talbert
and mr. William Bradford Huie our
distinguished guests was the honorable
Frederick R coudair jr. United States
representative from New York
travelers to the Olympic Winter Games at
all so from wherever they come we'll
find the familiar touch of home in
windows of fine jewelry stores launching
the world's most honored watch for the
fame of laun Jean is worldwide in the
mountain high city of La Paz Bolivia in
South America or historic Athens in
ancient Greece or the sacred city of
Mecca in Saudi Arabia in any of the
capitals of 77 countries of the free
world the watch of first choice with
discriminating men and women is
launching the world's most honored watch
the only watch in history to win 10
world's fair grand prizes twenty eight
gold medals and highest honors for
accuracy from the leading government
observatories
these are launching watches and if you
pay 70 150 or more for a watch for
yourself or as a gift you're paying the
price of a lone gene why not insist on
getting a long gene the world's most
honored watch premiere product of the
lawn gene wit nor wats company since
eighteen sixty six maker of watches of
the highest character launching
exclusive official watch for the Olympic
Winter Games of 1952
this is Frank Knight again inviting you
to join us every monday wednesday and
friday evening at this same time for the
long gene chronicles the television
journal of the important issues of the
are broadcast on behalf of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world on
it launching sold and service from coast
to coast by more than four thousand
leading jewelers who proudly display
this emblem agency for long jean wit nor
watches